but on the basis of the the sage minutes
which have been released suggesting we
could see hospitalizations in the not
too distant future reaching as high as
seven thousand isn't there a very strong
argument that the time to move from plan
a to plan b is now or at the very least
in the next in the next short interval
well my biggest take of yesterday was
seeing the health secretary talk about
how we might need to ask people to wear
masks and enclosed spaces uh in the
workplace surrounded by conservative mps
in their workplace none of them wearing
a mask it just gives me the sense of the
complacency that i feel is sometimes too
great a feature of the government when
responding to this in terms of how i
think this should be dealt with i'm
broadly i want the scientific advice to
be followed i think that rich people
have faced some real severe restrictions
and i think they want that authoritative
scientific base to do that
i'm really worried about things like the
anti-vaxx movement and how that is
affecting vaccinations so there's a lot
to do
that's definitely true to say that but
just
on the mass point this is one way we
explored it someday in some depths with
with mr travis because frankly to some
people it does look a little bit
confused would you uh would you would
the labour party
mandate the wearing of face masks in
public places again well you've got to
give people princes in a school setting
i would give head teachers the choice
behind that i think it's having the
tools in place to respond properly to
this but crucially let's still focus on
how we've fallen behind on vaccinations
let's make that the priority again
support the decision in terms of
children how that has been announced by
the chief medical officer i think that
is the right way for i'm afraid i think
too many people think this is now over
and i understand the fatigue that people
have i think i've mentioned to you a few
times a place like greater manchester
was in restrictions before the rest of
the country and that that has not been
easy for us but we can't at this stage
lose the gains of things like the
vaccination program we've got to
continue that message to people but but
just in terms of
of the pace of what is taking place
right now and and indeed the messaging
and you know sanjay javid said not that
long ago that these changes were were
irreversible clearly they are not
irreversible
do you think that people
are ready to return to tougher
restrictions given freedom day given the
weeks of you know relative freedom that
we that we have all enjoyed you think
people will do it if they're asked to do
it i think the fatigue is there and i
think we all understand that i think
that's why the messaging from the
government has to be clear has to be
consistent it has to be very clear what
would trigger that move to plan b and
what the status of that would be i think
politicians need to lead by example as
well and there's a lot about how the
house of commons has been operating the
last two weeks which has been a good
example of that just in terms of that
which we heard from yesterday what
specifically would labour do that is
different
to the conservative strategy as outlined
they say you know in terms of cases we
are relatively flat creeping up but
relatively flat and perhaps until that
changes would the party would your
party's position be pretty much the same
as it is the government's you know keep
everything under absolutely i'm happy
with a science-led
strategy i'm not looking for for
division points that aren't there i
think
many things i could say about how i feel
the government's been complacent i'm not
happy for instance with the uh way
borders have been treated throughout the
crisis again like that's something that
is well known but i want that
science-led strategy i mean
we've been criticized at times for this
we want the national strategy uncover to
succeed there's no
question of that where there is
complacency where we do criticize
individual things like the lack
situation of people coming into the
country that is about trying to make
sure the government's response is as
good as it can be when we as we are
heading into winter and i made this
point again to the health section we do
feel like we vacillate sometimes between
incredible optimism about what lies
ahead and incredible pessimism and where
on that sliding scale are you right now
i'm not sure i'd like to put it on the
scale i i think there has been a problem
i think some of the prime minister is
directly responsible for this in in some
of the rhetoric that is deployed this is
a slug i mean can you imagine if the
delta variant
our vaccine resistance had not been what
it was to it you know
that could have been a scenario and i
think we've got at all stages of this
just communicate that to the public make
sure they know that there is a proper
plan in place that it is being respected
everything is being done and i think
these language like freedom dates not
particularly helpful i would also say
again and you know we're going to talk
about this in terms of things like
universal credit i worry too many of the
lessons are being lost things that were
introduced in the pandemic that have got
us through it
the sense of well it's all over we can
just move on from that that is not the
right messaging from